so we switch gears now on the rich eisen
show to bring someone on who knows
nothing about fantasy football it's my
dad jeffrey lyons hey dad thanks for
checking in
how are you big guy
mike line two line two mike
he's just talking like no twofold got
nervous
i thought he was calling another one of
the guests
thanks for checking in
you know i trained with the giants for
three seasons so i know what it's like i
was a field goal kicker which your
grandfather arranged me to train with
them and it's a it's a tough time for
people down in the draft to impress a
coach when there are 60 guys on the
field you know so i feel for those guys
particularly in this kind of weather you
must have been in heaven last night even
though you're watching the yankees to
see the field of dreams game come to
life i know how much that movie means to
you what were your thoughts on the game
last night in the corn well you know i
sat next to james earl jones who i who
who i know uh at the critic screening
most stars don't go to critic screens
and he doesn't know anything about
baseball
yet he's been in so many baseball movies
and narrated them and before the movie
started he turned to me he said you know
baseball is zen well
i didn't know what that meant and then i
saw the movie and i was in tears and i
looked at him and he had a big grin on
his face you know i apparently i looked
it up and zen is a japanese way of
meditation
and uh it just really got to me it's my
favorite film of the 80s it's not a
baseball movie about fathers and sons
and the actor who played
uh kinsella's father who played kevin
costner's father had just lost his own
father in real life a few weeks before
and it just brought me back to having a
catch with my father and i'm glad we you
and i have those memories and it was a
great it came off very well you and i
were in london to see the red sox lose
to the yankees but it was baseball in
europe and this was another thing that's
happening and they're going to be doing
it every year now which i think is a
great idea i don't know how you get to
that part in iowa uh i don't know how
you get there but uh they did it
jeffrey lyons joining the rich eisen
show a real p1 i was talking about those
listeners the loyal listeners you have
here for the rich eisen show the big
guy's been listening to every episode
the last few weeks we appreciate it
jeffrey uh this is brockman here fellow
uh new englander and red sox fan the
most important part of last night's game
though jeffrey was the yankees lost so
yeah well i'm a new yorker i'm born and
bred in new york and that's makes me
even more diehard and ridiculous being a
red sox fan but makes me more insane
than you brockman who grew up in new
england that makes sense me growing up
in manhattan and skipping my high school
my son's high school graduation because
pedro is pitching that makes me insane
first things first patrons
in the 17th century there was a swiss
philosopher named blaze pascal no
relation to camilla pasquale the old
starter for the minnesota twins who said
the heart has reasons that reason itself
knows nothing about why did i marry a
girl from chicago aren't there a lot of
beautiful wonderful girls in new york
yeah but it's your you can't explain
love
back big facts jeffrey lyons do you have
a question or you just you just no i was
just pointing out to him that the most
important part of last night's game was
not the pageantry and the beauty it was
that the yankees lost yes it was how it
what how it happened that baseball when
you when you explained baseball to a
european and you say if if your team
real madrid is when beating barcelona
eight nil as they say and they're two
minutes to go on the game's over in
baseball it's over when it's over and i
thought it was an amazing example of why
baseball is my favorite sport there's no
clock and you can always win it's most
it's highly unlikely but that win last
night was astonishing and yes for as a
red sox fan
even though they're on the downside
right now that was big for the red sox
too so it was just sensational jeffrey
lyons taking over the rich eisenhower
ben lions in for rich on now with the
big guy
mike del tufo says there are no great
movie uh no great sports moments in the
1980s there were none really for red sox
fans describe to our audience what it
was like to be living in new york from
new york on television in new york as a
red sox fan during the 1980s well first
of all to go back a little bit i had i
had i drew the assignment to greet the
yankees coming home in 1978 that
horrifying year when the red sox blew a
fourteen game lead fourteen and a half
game lead in august and i had to greet
the yankees at the airport and some of
them recognized me apparently and
started giving it to me and i deserved
it i guess but wait a minute the uh the
home run by dave henderson to win the
american league pennant a couple of
games later uh was one of the great
moments of the 80s for red sox fans not
many but the world series was great
until disaster struck but uh you put
those behind you and they're the only
team to win four world championships
this century that's i look at those i
have a picture of me holding three of
the uh or three of the statues and i at
dire moments like this when they need to
make up so much ground i think of those
good times too were you ever scared for
your safety though riding the train to
the bronx when entire subway cars were
chanting lying sucks ryan sucks because
i was terrified
well i i appreciate no not really that
was all it was all in good fun i guess
uh although a friend of ours uh got
socked in the face at the yankee stadium
for wearing a red sock hat but i've worn
my red sock hat running with the bulls
in pamplona six times going up the nile
explaining to the captain of the boat
what uh you know what what red sox
nation is you you wear it everywhere i
wore i wore a red sox pen on my tuxedo
to three academy awards if you know you
weren't and people walk up to me on the
street in new york and they say hey go
red sox so i say where's your pen i got
to share the abuse come on where's
something
hey mr jeff this is tj here and first of
all i want to say congratulations you
raised a very fine young man you've been
having a great time with him thanks man
um thank you thank you so many things
i'd want to ask you and i'm not going to
bring up the 86 world series as a match
fan but i will say this to you
is there any movie and i'm sure there
has to be one where you watched and you
were like you just panned it you gave it
is six thumbs down you hated it
you can't judge art with them those are
my competitors
regretted the review is that what your
other question yes so but then you went
back after you you published a review
and you went back and watched the game
was like maybe i was i was wrong
there is one um woody allen who i like
and i'm not uh you know i'm not
explaining any of the michigan nonsense
in his life i came to my father's
funeral i can't forget that woody allen
uh made a movie called the front
about the blacklisting and there were
some very funny moments in it and i
didn't think that was that really happen
and i did the research i should have
done beforehand and i realized there was
a lot of gallows humor when these great
screenwriters had to use uh uh synonym
pseudonyms
uh to to work and what he captured that
so i did i did almost an apology a
review of it later and he thanked me so
that's the only time doesn't mean i'm i
can't happen again
and your chase changed too because ben's
going to tell me i'm i'm on the vhs box
for juwana man
for a quote so you can have that quote
that's right you know but he also likes
movies that i don't like it at all
depends but it art is such a flexible
thing
that you you you you can't be absolutely
anything and and every nowadays
especially everybody's a critic
so uh i'm just concerned now now that
i'm seeing a lot of movies online about
how the red sox are gonna fit uh
schwarberg in their lineup
and why verdugo is taking the five four
or five day paternity leave when you're
supposed to take a three-day paternity
leave come on get back in the lineup
first things first you know
i really feel like you and chris brown
dad
as a red sox fan put the baby down and
get back in the lineup faster come on
dad
brock holt who the slowest pitch in
baseball history the other day for a
strike a 31 mile an hour pitch an arc
is pitch for a strike 31 miles an hour
and and the guy it was like ted williams
had that thrown adam in an all-star game
and he had asked another player i think
rudy york he asked them how should i
face this guy's going to throw me an
epis [ __ ] and he told him in the second
pitch that that the picture through
wound up in the red sox bull uh and and
the bullpen so there is a way to hit
those guys these things play i go over
lineups when i'm trying to go to sleep i
go over old lineups to see what see how
they can improve and you have no idea
ben has an idea of the obsession but you
guys don't know he's he's been filling
us in workout called the boston red sox
all-time
all-stars which picks every player at
every position and the greatest of all
time and honorable mentions and and also
a chapter on players who didn't know
wore the red sox uniform on their way to
cooperstown and the red sox are the only
team to have two players to get three
hits in one inning that's a record that
will never be broken only team to have
two guys guys nicknamed the hawk can you
name them ben can you name the two
harrison is one yeah
you saw the other guy named the hawk
andre dawson andre dawson you saw him
throw out a guy not at the red sox but
he threw a guy out at the plate a guy
named caccini i think who played up in a
borrowed uniform so there are all sorts
of quirks with the team they're also the
last team to integrate to their because
their owner was racist they tried out
two young players named jackie robinson
and willie mays and i think roberto
clemente and their racist management
said uh get them off the field can you
imagine having those three on your team
so that's you know love is not perfect
but uh those people are long gone thank
goodness jeffrey lyons on the rich eisen
show the first mishigas on the j on the
rich isaac show in show history i
believe
first time when i was on this week
dad i will see you next week out in long
island i look forward to it thanks for
checking in thanks guys it's been doing
it's been great listening all week i i
do listen to the show otherwise but not
quite as closely as one tennis co-host i
understand understandable i hope so
jeffrey you're meant to be well tell mom
i love her pleasure
i'll see you next week all right thanks
guys hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here